you
[Music]
thank you all for coming I pleased to
introduce Dan ports who's a professor at
the University of Washington where he
leads the distributed systems research
lab research group he his primary focus
is on distributed systems in a modern
scale data center and he works on making
them more reliable more efficient easier
to use more secure and with this work
he's had lots of papers in OSD ispn SDI
he's had a couple of best paper Awards
even and with him being just across the
lake with several students he is he is a
good source for potential collaborations
in the future so I'm very pleased to
welcome here him here to give a talk to
us and I hope you'll all join me in
welcoming him thanks Jay and thanks
everyone for coming it's great to be
here and I'm excited to tell you about
some of the things that my students and
I have been working on over at u-dub so
I've given this talk a bunch of places
and usually I need to start out by
convincing people that distributed
systems and data centers are relevant to
their lives so I'm guessing this
probably isn't a place where I really
need to make that case
but indeed you know our applications
these days are being built in just the
data center which means that we have to
build them as distributed systems and we
do that because our applications you
know are just too big to fit on one
machine we need them to be scalable to
huge data set sizes we increasingly need
that data to be constantly changing by
interactive processes so we need the
system to be able to respond quickly
within a few milliseconds and we need
them to be more reliable than a single
computer because users expect their
applications never to go down which
means that application developers have
some really hard problems to face about
how to build systems that are in fact
scalable fast and reliable
they have to be able to build reliable
applications even though at the data
centers scale they're always
servers that have failed they've got to
handle massive levels of concurrency
which we've always had problem dealing
with concurrency even on a single
machine and race conditions but now
we're asking developers to handle
millions of concurrent users constantly
updating data and they get an even
harder problem that is specific to the
distributed systems context which is
that when there are multiple copies of
data either for performance reasons or
for reliability reasons these copies
might not all be the same so they have
to reason about all the possible states
the data could be in and how to keep
that data consistent and you know all of
this really leads us to what is kind of
the paradox of distributed systems that
we were building these things because we
needed our applications to be faster and
more scalable and more reliable than a
single machine but we've got all these
problems and if we don't get them right
we're going to wind up with something
that is slower less scalable and even
less reliable than a single machine or
even completely incorrect so there's an
opportunity for systems research to help
developers build reliable and scalable
distributed systems with practical
system software and specifically I'm
going to talk about building storage
systems that provide strong guarantees
in order to simplify application
development and I'm specifically
referring to two things here one of them
is strongly consistent replication where
the system is going to make multiple
copies of a data object and making sure
they're always going to be the same even
when there are concurrent updates and
failures and that's really great for
developers because they don't have to
worry about the fact that there are
multiple copies of their data that that
are constantly failing they can just
treat it as though there's one copy
that's always up and then the second one
is distributed transaction support where
developers can group operations into
transactions and have the system making
sure they're executed in atomic unit
even when the data is stored in
different places so they don't have to
worry about concurrency and race
conditions between the components of a
transaction and they can imagine that
only one of transaction is running at a
time these aren't new ideas of course
they have been around for many decades
but traditionally these abstractions
impose a really high performance cost
and that leads application developers to
be stuck between a rock and a hard place
because they either have to have these
nice guarantees but have a system that's
potentially not going to scale and not
going to meet their performance
requirements or they're going to have to
architect for high performance and go to
a lot of trouble to deal with all of
those distributed systems challenges
that I was talking about before so this
is where my groups research fits in
we've been building practical systems to
make it easier to build distributed
applications by having strong guarantees
it with low performance cost and we'll
show in some cases that this can give us
strong properties with very little or no
overhead so we've done this in a lot of
different areas fault tolerant
replication transactional storage
systems new types of applications like
in-memory caches I've also done some
work in the past in serializable
transactions and conventional databases
including the concurrency control
mechanism that's in the Postgres
database that many of you may have used
in this talk I'm going to focus
specifically on three systems mostly
I'll talk about fault tolerant
replication with two systems called
speculative Paxos and Network ordered
paxos and then I'll talk a little bit
about some ongoing work we have on
building distributed transactional
storage in a system called eros all
these systems provide a strong
replication and strong transactional
guarantees
we have really low overhead that is
close to indistinguishable from systems
with weaker guarantees and what is
making all this possible is that we're
using a new approach to designing our
distributed systems by taking advantage
of the unique properties and
capabilities of the data center
environment so the plan for this talk is
that to give you a bit of an overview at
a high level of this approach first and
then we'll look at two case studies of
this in the context of fault tolerant
replication and then have a brief look
at how we can use this for the harder
problem of building distributed
transactions in a larger scale storage
system so if we start from the really
high level view of distributed systems
if the data centers are unit of
computation and we've got all of these
communication and failure challenges in
it we need to be able to use this we
need to use distributed algorithms to
make sure that the system provides
correct and reliable behavior in spite
of the fact that there are many nodes
some of which might be failing a
canonical example of one of these
distributed algorithms is paxos which
many of you are probably familiar with
if you're not it's an algorithm that's
used to deal with failures and
distributed systems by having a
consensus protocol that makes sure that
the nodes agree on the state of the
system even when some of the replicas
can fail and when the network is
unreliable we're seeing this used
everywhere in data center applications
today both we're keeping critical
services available the things that
manage and coordinate the other systems
in the data center and we're also seeing
it being used as the basis for
persistent storage in distributed
databases in addition to or sometimes in
place of writing data durably to disk
you see this for example in google
spanner so
the high level way that we generally
build distributed systems is to first
model the environment that we expect
them to run in and then design a
distributed algorithm like paxos that
has the properties we want and then
we'll go and build distributed systems
that use this algorithm to implement a
real system and previously these steps
are done by completely different people
and sometimes they do this you know
decades apart
we've paxos and related algorithms were
originally developed in the late 80s and
early 90s and we didn't really start
seeing them being deployed in even
research systems for five to ten years
and practical systems until maybe 10
years ago when we started having large
data center environments so what that
means is that the model that people use
when designing these algorithms doesn't
always closely match the in today's
environment in the data center so what I
mean by this is that distributed systems
are traditionally designed completely
independently of the network that
they're running on and that means that
the algorithm designers treat the
network as some kind of black box where
they have to make really conservative
assumptions about it so a standard one
is the asynchronous Network model where
we have to treat the network as an
adversary that's causing arbitrary
packets to be lost
delayed reordered or potentially even
modified in some other way and that gets
used in algorithms like Paxos and is
responsible for a lot of complexity
there so that's a totally reasonable
thing to do in the internet because we
know that all these things can and do
happen and there isn't really a whole
lot we could do about it anyway but the
question is is this really the right
approach for the data center because the
data center network isn't a mysterious
cloud it's that we actually know quite a
bit about data
network it's a structured network that's
designed to provide certain properties
in fact the Dana Center network really
is fundamentally different than the
Internet in a bunch of different ways so
for one thing it's a more reliable
network obviously we do have failures in
the data center network and packets
being lost but it's really happening at
a different scale than it would be on
the internet and there's a potential to
make the net data center network a lot
more predictable because we know the
topology and the route the packets can
take in it but most importantly there's
a lot more flexibility in the data
center network it's being run by a
single organization so that you can
imagine actually making changes to the
data center network in a way that you
really can't do in the wide area
Internet and then on the technological
side you've got modern networking
hardware that has some pretty advanced
processing capabilities that you can
take advantage of and increasingly these
capabilities are being exposed to
application developers and
administrators through technologies like
software-defined networking so what that
means for us is that we've got a new
opportunity for the first time now we
can really start to think about Co
designing the distributed systems with
the underlying data center network so
that's what we my group has been doing
we've been looking at how to build new
distributed systems using this approach
which is to say that rather than making
worst-case assumptions about the data
center network we'll try to understand
the actual properties it has in practice
but also to engineer new network
primitives that give us new properties
in the data center network and then
build algorithms that are specifically
designed to take advantage of these
properties in order to give you better
performance or better reliability so our
first set of work in this area has been
with fault tolerant replication and this
is joint work with my students
Joanne Lee Naveen Sharma and Ellis
Michel at u-dub
and we've built a couple different
systems here these are addressing the
problem of dealing with failures in the
data center environment so server
failures really are the common case not
the exception they're constantly
happening and the standard approach that
we use is some form of replication like
state machine replication for critical
services conceptually this is really
simple we're just going to take a
service and make multiple copies of it
on different replicas and make sure
they're all executing the same
operations in the same order which means
that even if some of these replicas fail
the remaining system can still handle
client requests the challenge here is to
make sure that they are in fact
processing the same operations in the
same order and that's the standard way
to do that is with an algorithm like
paxos and we're going to talk about how
we use our code design approach to
improve the performance of paxos so in
order to do this we first need to
understand how it works and what the
performance bottlenecks are more
importantly as a distributed systems
researcher federal law requires me
whenever I have this many people in a
room to explain taxes to them so we're
going to do that it has a reputation for
being really complicated but in fact in
the normal case it's conceptually really
quite simple
we've got a set of clients that are
submitting operations to a group of
replicas we have designated one of these
replicas as the leader and made it
responsible for ordering requests and of
course we've got a protocol for how to
elect a new leader if it should fail and
when a client sends a request it goes to
the leader which assigns it a sequence
number and then sends it off to the
other replicas which will send back an
acknowledgment if they're prepared to
execute that operation this is a two
fate that looks like a two-phase commit
protocol if you're familiar with that
and once the leader has heard from a
majority of replicas it can go ahead and
execute the operation and notify
everyone including the client of its
successful outcome
so the important things here are one for
correctness that we had all of the
operations assigned a consistent order
by a single point in the system here
it's the leader and of course a lot of
complexity comes in later and making
sure that if there's a failure we
maintain that order and then the other
important part is that nothing actually
gets executed until a majority of the
replicas have seen them which means that
if there's some failure of a might of
less than a majority of nodes in the
system we can recover from that so just
by looking at this graph we can see a
bunch of the important performance
properties of Paxos in terms of latency
there are four phases to this protocol
for message delays in terms of
throughput what we've seen being the
limiting factor in practice is the
number of messages that need to be
handled by a bottleneck server here at
the leader which has to process 2n
messages and we're going to be able to
improve on both of these both in a
theoretical sense and in an empirical
sense by code is Co designing with a
date with a data center network property
so how are we going to do that well we
saw that paxos was using a leader
replica to order requests and the theme
for both of our projects in this area is
asking can we use the data center
network instead to do this kind of
ordering it was actually done this in
two different systems the first one was
a system called speculative Paxos and
mostly ordered multicast this was an N
SGI a couple of years ago the what we
did in this work was to engineer the
network to give us this primitive called
mostly ordered multicast or mam which
has a best-effort ordering property it
gives you a certain property in the
common case and then we really exploit
that common case to build an incredibly
efficient replication protocol
speculative Paxos later we built a
system called
Network ordered paxos or no paxos on top
of a more complicated Network primitive
and in this work what we were doing was
not trying to provide a common case but
to provide an actual guarantee by taking
advantage of some new advanced
processing capabilities in data center
network hardware that led us have a
simpler and even more efficient protocol
called Network ordered paxos both of
these systems give us some nice
performance results so speculative Paxos
was the first replication protocol that
could outperform existing systems on
both latency and throughput at the same
time in the past you generally had to
choose between trading off one for the
other and network ordered Paxos not only
outperforms spective Paxos but it's able
to give us state machine replication
with less than a 2% overhead relative to
a nun replicated system which means that
it's possible to avoid this traditional
trade off between strongly consistent
replication and good performance so let
me start by talking about speculative
Paxos and as I said this project was all
about the common case so what we wanted
to do was to make sure that we could
provide a certain ordering property
called mostly ordered multicast in the
normal case and then design a
replication protocol called speculative
pesos that was optimized for that common
case so what is the ordering property
that we wanted well what we'd really
like to get out of the network is a
consistent ordering of concurrent
messages which is to say that if we've
got multiple clients sending messages to
the same group of replicas and one
replica gets operation a followed by
operation B then we'd like them to all
get a followed by B you can see how
having this would really simplify your
your life if you're trying to implement
rep
location and indeed if you actually
could achieve this in a fully reliable
way you wouldn't even need any of the
complexity of a replication protocol
like Paxos but in order to actually
achieve this you have to solve a problem
that is in fact equivalent to consensus
it's nearly impossible to get it right
in the event of Network failures so what
we found was a reasonable option instead
was to provide this as a best effort
property which is to say that it holds
most of the time but the network doesn't
guarantee that it's going to provide it
all the time if say if there are
failures and that's going to make this
something that's actually practical to
implement but I should note that
existing data center networks and
existing multicast protocols certainly
don't provide this property already so
we can see this if we look at an example
here we've got a really simple data
center network where we've got three
clients talking to three replicas via a
network that's consists of five switches
in a in a multi rooted tree
configuration this kind of topology in
some form is is very common obviously in
a real data center network you'd have a
lot more switches and a whole lot more
servers but we can see just looking at
this
why reordering of packets would become a
problem the reason is that multicast
packets will take routes of different
lengths and potentially different levels
of congestion and that can lead to
replicas getting messages in a different
order so if we've got this client on the
Left sending a message to all the
replicas it's going to arrive at replica
one before the other two replicas
because it only has to travel a path of
length two versus a path of length four
to the other destinations and similarly
if the client on the right is sending a
message it will arrive at replicas three
before the other two replicas so you
know it shouldn't be too hard to imagine
that if these messages were being sent
at around the same time that some of the
replicas would be receiving the blue
message fall by the read message and
some of them the other way around
and that's exactly what we wanted to
avoid so in order to address this we
used a bunch of network engineering
techniques to reduce the probability of
this happening and the main one is
rather than always taking the shortest
path directly to each of the replicas
we're going to first route the multicast
messages through one of these route
switches that are going to be
equidistant from the receivers and
that's going to normalize the path
length so now if this client is sending
this message rather than taking the
direct route to replica one it first
travels up to the route switch and then
back down and that means that all the
paths have the same length there's a lot
less variability in the message delivery
time and although it's not a guarantee
this means the chance of having a packet
reordering turns out to be a lot lower
now if you step back a little bit what
we've done here is actually something
that's really counterintuitive we're
asking the network to take longer to
deliver certain packets which is
something you'd never want to do if you
were designing a network in isolation
but we'll see in a minute that when we
combine this with our co.design protocol
we get a system that has better overall
latency yes yeah before you were talking
about the ordering with respect to the
purple messages and bright red messages
right going up to the route of the
routers there doesn't really help you
with that at all right and in terms of
the ordering between the two sets so
each message will individually be routed
through the route switches and that
means that the window of potential
reorderings becomes smaller it's
certainly not the case that this
certainly doesn't guarantee you that
there will be no reordered messages but
empirically the likelihood of having a
packet or having you know one of the
replicas get the red message and the
other blue message and one of the other
replicas the other way around
drops by a couple orders of magnitude as
a result of this but the verbal message
would fall to the router on the right
right yeah right
does that clear it up at all or yeah
okay it I understand that it reduces in
practice but given that the two routers
are independent and all the messages
that flow down from them are also
independent right you would think that
there would still be a lot of
reorderings between the red and the
purple when it gets when it comes to the
relevance right so that definitely there
are some and we'll see a little later
that in our next system we can eliminate
we can really eliminate them here what
we're just trying to do is to reduce the
probability so this is really kind of an
empirical approach that we're able to
bring it down from potentially 1% to
more like 0.01 percent or less so what
we can do with that is design
speculative paxos which is a new state
machine replication protocol provides
the same properties as Paxos and
actually the same guarantees which is to
say that even though we're going to rely
on its ordering property for performance
reasons in the common case we don't
actually rely on it for the protocol to
be correct so you know as Ricardo noted
that you can in fact get packets
delivered out of order and the
speculative paksas protocol is totally
resilient to that it remains correct and
provides the same correctness properties
as pesos so the actual protocol here is
really quite simple what we do is have
the client just send the message
directly to all the replicas using this
new network primitive and each of the
replicas will just assume that it's
likely the other replicas got the
message in the same order so they'll
speculatively execute it and respond to
the client there are a couple details
that we need to include here to make
this work one is that when the replicas
respond the client they're going to
include a hash of their current state
which means
that the client will be able to check
for matching responses from enough
replicas and if it gets enough then it
will know that the operation has
successfully executed for technical
reasons related to fast taxes if you're
familiar with that we actually need to
use a larger quorum size than you would
in traditional Paxos here 2/3 or 3/4 of
the replicas rather than 1/2 but the
nice thing about this is that we've
dramatically reduced the complexity of
the replication protocol before we were
talking about 4 message delays to
complete an operation and here we only
have 2 in terms of throughput we don't
have a bottleneck replicas anymore each
replica is processing you know only one
incoming message and sending one
response so we're pretty much at the
theoretical minimum here which means
that you're as we'll see in a minute
this gives us some nice purse abstention
improvement in both throughput and
latency now what's making this possible
is that we had to use speculation which
is to say that replicas are executing
requests before they know the definite
ordering and that does mean that they
might have to roll back operations if
they didn't execute fit them in the
right order
this isn't practical to do for all of
the for all applications it happens that
there are a lot of things you want to
replicate in the data center where it's
not too much trouble to achieve this
like in version storage systems but one
really important property we do have
here is that the clients always know
that their request succeeded because
they can compare the responses from the
replicas and only taken up matching ones
so the clients don't need to speculate
on the responses which is important
because that's a lot harder yeah too
much yeah
is it possible the drivers on the
nucleus
are you kidding like that yeah we have
actually seen that a problem in practice
that the knick will try very hard to
keep packets from the same sender
arriving in the same order but not to
provide the kind of ordering your needs
so we'd have to disable oversee inside
scaling in order to hear that okay and
what do they I guess you know what does
that really mean you're welcome
customers but the other question that I
have is what happens to a community well
good a much it go to be ordered can
screen that's not to be me like the
audience actually one but because so we
actually use in this case the a hash
chain of the operations so you can think
of a hash of the log of all operations
so you would in fact detect a reordering
if you had commutative operations you
could likely use a slightly different
mechanism to you know not detect
reorderings that you didn't care about
but we haven't you know we haven't done
that specifically yes I'm here to
cooperation because now yes exactly so
that's the next part which is that the
replicas aren't normally talking to each
other
so how do they make sure that they're in
the same state and know when they need
to roll back and in order to do that
they periodically run a synchronization
protocol every you know a few thousand
operations or every few milliseconds
where they just check to make sure that
they're in the same state and if there
is a divergence they're going to run a
reconciliation protocol and this looks a
lot like the slow path of standard Paxos
or a view change in you stamp
replication or raft where the replicas
are all going to pause their execution
stop processing new requests elect a
leader and exchange the log of
operations and then this leader is just
going to decide on the correct ordering
of these operations in a way that's
consistent with anything that might have
returned to the clients and notify the
replicas of the proper order and this
then requires some of the replicas to
rollback and reacts
keep the requests this is a pretty
expensive process both because of the
robach and because we have to stop the
system while we run this process but so
that sex this goes to show that
co.design approach which is that we have
a really fast common case and a really
slow uncommon case but we're going to a
lot of effort to engineer the network in
order to make this uncommon case rare it
only happens when the ordering property
is violated in the network how far you
have to go back yeah that's a part of
what the synchronization protocol does
which is to periodically make sure that
you're in the same state and if you are
then you can you know throw away your
speculation records because you won't
have to roll back further apart you keep
that long back so we generally kept this
a couple hundred operations obviously it
would depend on what the operations
actually are so in order to understand
the performance of the system we built a
emulated data center network in our
machine room by connecting a lot of
switches to each other in a with an
awful lot of very short tables which did
not leave our IT people very happy with
us we this emulated data center network
provides mostly ordered multicast and
we've compared a variety of existing
replication protocols on this system so
here we're comparing them both in terms
of latency where lower is better and
throughput where better is to the right
so first the obvious comparison is
between a standard Paxos algorithm and
actually here I'm referring to a multi
Paxos leader based approach which is the
standard optimization you would use this
is also equivalent to view stamp
replication or raft if you're familiar
with those and speculative Paxos gives
us four times the throughput and 40%
lower
than this standard taxes approach would
would do which is a pretty nice result
on it by itself but to really put this
in context we can look at kind of what
the existing best practices were in
terms of optimized protocols and
traditionally you had a choice between
running a latency optimized protocol
like fast paxos which gives you better
latency but not actually any more
throughput or running a throughput
optimization like batching requests
which would give you much higher
throughput at the cost of additional
latency and this is actually a variant
of batching that's designed to minimize
the latency latency impact
so with speculative Paxos were able to
give you the best of both worlds which
is that we can give you better latency
than fast Paxos and with that while
still giving you the kind of throughput
benefit that you would get out of adding
batching so that is a really nice
performance result there so just to
summarize the spec of the faxes work
this was our first foray into Co
designing protocols and data center
networks and we showed that we could
achieve better throughput and latency
than traditional replication protocols
by taking advantage of the engineered
network in the data center and an
important thing to note here is that
this is actually something you can
deploy today because this requires some
simple changes to how packets get routed
which you can do with existing
software-defined networks but we wanted
to do better than this and so the
question we started asking after we had
finished this work was well speculative
Paxos was all about the engineering the
network for the common case yeah
yes that's definitely a possibility that
you could delay a packet in software
rather than routing it along a lower
path a longer path we didn't do that
because the latency isn't always fully
predictable on congested links and also
that there isn't there is additional
bandwidth utilization as well I meant if
you're saying that data is not
predictable that also means potentially
means that means queuing these days are
concerned opposed to your class you have
the buttons are the same right so how
does that affect that that does
I think after path lanes queuing effects
are probably the largest factor for
certain applications you can avoid some
of the queuing effects by using quality
of service obviously that comes with a
set of trade-offs that are kind of
obvious in whether whether you can
actually prioritize the traffic ahead of
others it's practical for a lot of
coordination metadata services and
actually if you're interested in this
you can take a look at our NS GI paper
which actually evaluates the impact of a
few different design options for how you
would do this and what that means to the
reordering rate you know using one
switch multiple switches quality of
service no quality of service that kind
of thing yeah so I'm going to instruct
you experience when turning up receiver
side scalar we haven't we haven't had a
then that hasn't been the limiting case
for the state machine replication
because we are using an architecture
here where ultimately the requests have
to be eggs have to be serialized and
then executed by a single thread so
having them having the NIC deliver them
in a single queue it is not having a
huge effect on overall system throughput
okay but then you're not multiplexing
correct you you know what we would
really like is a way to have packets
destined for the same replica group go
to one queue but different replica
groups go to a different view that's not
something you can do with RSS of our
education for your entrance question so
your NEPA paper actually that
technologies of the overhead on the
network yes okay yes we did that in
simulations with a data center network
using workload measurements from
Microsoft data center study so in this
suspect of the packs this is all about
the common case but we wanted to start
asking afterwards can we get actual
ordering guarantees out of the network
and use that to build a simpler more
efficient and more robust system instead
and the thing that's making this
possible is that there's a new
generation of data center switches that
are coming out that have flexible data
plane packet processing architectures
which essentially mean that you are
allowed to do a really small amount of
computation in the switch on every
packet which means you get this
computation really for free as the
packet traverses the switch and so we
started asking you know can we use this
to do part of the replication processing
for us and get a simpler protocol the
result was what we called Network
ordered Paxos or no Paxos which makes it
possible to replicate systems with
essentially no Paxos performance
overhead and this was a paper from OSGi
last year so the obvious question in
this work is if we want to use the
network to do something what should we
have it do so we can look at this as a
spectrum of network guarantees on one
side we've got the traditional
asynchronous Network which is provides
no guarantees in the network and
requires the full complexity of
something like paxos and then at the
other extreme when I put speculative
paxos you know assent just to the right
of this because it's only giving us
properties in the common case no actual
guarantees at the other extreme you
could imagine having a totally ordered
and completely reliable Network and that
would be a really great world to live in
because at that point you wouldn't have
to run any replication protocol you just
send the messages and the replicas would
just execute them and do exactly the
same thing and the problem with this of
course is that there's no real way to
implement this other than like you could
imagine trying to push Paxos directly
into the switches and guarantee
reliability that way but that is going
to be inefficient and definitely trying
to do something in hardware that it's
really not suited for so the question we
were asking in this work is you know is
there space in the middle of this
spectrum where you know using our
knowledge of how these replication
protocols work we can find a model that
actually provides performance benefits
but at the same time is something you
can actually manage to implement
efficiently in a data center and of
course if I'm talking to you about this
the answer is yes our proposal was what
we called ordered unreliable multicast
or oum and the key idea here was that in
state machine replication we needed all
replicas to process the same set of
operations which is a reliability
property and process them in the same
order which is an ordering property and
in a traditional design the replication
protocol is responsible for both but our
key idea is to separate the ordering
from the reliable delivery so that the
network is responsible for the ordering
guarantee and the replication protocol
is responsible for relied providing
reliability so the reason I'm arguing
that this is a practical approach is
there's a fairly straightforward way to
implement this that is we designate
something in the network as a sequin
sir this could be a one of these
flexible packet processing switches and
it has a really simple job which is just
to a put sequence numbers into packets
so it's going to maintain a counter for
every replica group and we're going to
configure the network using open flow or
something like that before it all Oum
messages for a replica group to the
right sequencer which will just
increment the sequence number right that
counter value into the packet header and
send it off to all the receivers and
then once you've got these sequence
numbers the receivers can just look at
them to detect when messages were
reordered based on out of order sequence
numbers or detect drop messages by
noticing gaps in the number sequence
utter it will be so we're not
guaranteeing that the sequencer is
reliable so it's just a single point of
ordering but not a reliable one we'll
talk about that in a bit what we
resolved it in the protocol
fundamentally what we're saying here is
that adding this sequence are in and the
sequence number is going to change our
network model just a little bit and that
it's note that it it's no longer a
totally unordered Network but it has an
ordering property and this is going to
give us some really nice properties when
we go to design a replication protocol
for it
so in it just to give you an example of
how this works
here we've got two senders sending
multicast messages concurrently using
oum and messages get forwarded to the
sequencer which stamps them with the
next counter value and sends them off in
the normal case the receivers can see
that they're receiving the messages in
the right order but there's no guarantee
that all the messages will be delivered
so this one for example doesn't make it
to the middle replica but when the next
message comes along that middle replica
is going to see that it got messages 1 2
& 4 and it will know that it must have
lost message number 3
and that means it will send a
notification to the application level
code Arno Paxos system telling us that
that message was lost so why is this
going to be useful well from the
perspective of replication protocol
first the network is already ordering
the messages so we don't need the
replicas to coordinate to agree on that
order and second we've got this drop
detection property where replicas will
know that they've lost a message and
when they do exactly what message was
lost so the protocol only needs to
explicitly coordinate when the messages
actually get lost now this lets us build
the a print and even a really simple
protocol for how this works to do
replication so clients just send the
request to all the replicas with oum and
in the normal case since the message the
network is guaranteeing ordering the
replicas will all receive the request in
the same order and immediately reply
back to the client the client is going
to wait for a response from majority of
the replicas including the leader and
this has the performance properties we
saw in speculative Paxos which is to say
that if there's no coordination between
the replicas and the optimal to delay is
for latency but it's also less expensive
than speculative Paxos because we're
able to eliminate some of the more
expensive things we did there like
speculative execution and comparing
summary hashes because the network is
giving you this ordering property rather
than just a best-effort that could
potentially fail obviously though there
are a lot of ways things can go wrong
here
when there's a message that's lost this
gets detected by the network layer based
on the gap in sequence numbers but we
still have to recover from it and the
way we do this is by having the non
leader replicas ask the leader if they
receive the missing message the leader
replica if it's missing the message
itself
we'll run a coordination protocol - but
looks like a single round of paxos to
get the replicas to all agree never to
process that message and move on
the nice thing about this protocol is
it's lightweight in particular if one
replica misses a message the other
replicas can continue executing the
other operations while it gets caught
back up we don't have to do this thing
we did in speculative Paxos where we had
to stop the system in order to sort out
requests we should be doing in what
order and again that's because there's a
ordering guarantee here whereas there
wasn't before as you said there can also
be failures of this of a sequencer as
well as the leader and the way we deal
with this is by replacing the leader and
running a view change protocol it and in
the no paxos layer that makes sure that
all the replicas are in the consistent
state that is to say that they're going
to detect the failure of a sequencer and
when stop to agree on what the old
sequencer successfully did and then
start processing requests from a new
sequencer I won't go into all the
details of this you know we have a paper
that explains the protocol and proves it
correct and all of that what I do want
to mention is how do we implement the
sequencer and there are a few different
ways the most efficient way would be to
take advantage of switches as a
sequencer which has essentially no cost
since the packets have to go through
these switches anyway and these
programmable switches are able to
execute this as part of their existing
processing pipeline this is something
you can do we've implanted in p4 so you
can deploy it to some upcoming switches
that are becoming available this year
from barefoot and caveum and others but
we don't actually have these switches
yet so we've built a prototype in the
form of a middle box using a network
processor which is a specialized piece
of hardware for low latency packet
processing we connect it to the route
switches it's giving us the same
functionality but it has an additional
latency cost because the packet has to
be transmitted to this device yes
there's a varying that
really so at any given point we're only
using one but the neck in general we're
only using that one sequencer for a
particular replica group and the amount
of traffic destined for that replica
group is going to be a lot slower than
the capacity of a switch you can use a
different sequencer for different
replica groups so the end result is good
performance so we can revisit this graph
we were looking at before and add in no
paxos so we've got even more of a
performance improvement now we're up to
a 4.7 X improvement in throughput and
close to a 50% reduction in latency
relative to classic multi Paxos this is
also throughput that's 25 percent higher
than your batching throughput optimized
version of Paxos with one sixth of the
latency but to put this in perspective
we also compare it against a none
replicated server that's just doing our
pcs to a single machine and not
providing you any fault tolerance at all
no paxos is able to get you through put
that's within two percent of this
unreplicated system and latency that's
within a few microseconds with most of
the additional latency costs coming from
the fact that we had to use this middle
box prototype rather than an in switch
sequencer can you comment on how do
these costs of protocol subtractive with
this help they don't Technic is the
answer
these are protocols that you're running
inside the data center I was hoping that
you saw the boys they're hoping you have
some magic bullet where you can actually
even without deciding afraid not
you know fundamentally there's a problem
here because we're talking about
multicast Datagram protocols and SSL is
very connection oriented so we've got a
fundamental disconnect there already I'm
not aware of people generally you know
SSL encrypting this kind of traffic
although certainly there are reasons why
you might want to
yeah Rosario and you looked at the
impact of the background traffic on the
network or the performance especially
speculative accidents yeah so this is an
issue really for secular paxos not so
much no paxil
unless you get to congestion losses
right definitely there is an impact
there it's pretty sensitive to how the
network it the network utilization and
that sort of thing
quality of service helps that's a
possibility because that gives you more
predictable queueing behavior but you
know again this is one of those cases
where we don't have enough data to
really understand data center workloads
to make it more of a definitive
statement about that just that there is
a wide range of abuse cases where the
speculative approach is possible and
Network ordered approach doesn't have
that bottleneck so in yourself you have
a way to grab where you sort of increase
the background traffic which is actually
foreground traffic rank design right
how are you increase it and then see
what the impact is on speculative boxes
yeah such a graph definitely exists I
want to say that it's in the paper but I
can't say that for sure because it's
been a couple of years but definitely
we've looked at that I'm happy to talk
about that more yeah there is Oh blue in
the sequence the computing software just
to get an idea of a more CEO wanna go
yeah we actually have also built this
with a completely software based
sequencer and interestingly we didn't
expect this to give you much of a
benefit because the point of this work
was to move something into the hardware
it turns out by using this restructuring
of the taxes protocol in this way you're
able to get essentially the same
throughput benefit with with this
software based sequencer but not a
latency benefit so it winds up being you
know somewhere around here on the graph
and that's with you know no special
hardware just some network routing rules
one no right now this is all in memory
replication
all right so that's question yeah are
you familiar with this state machine
replication portable clock clock our
area some Erickson
no no so basically what it does is so if
you have many replicas what it does is
every replica proposes with its own
physical time stamping and that's the
only so that's right that gives you the
ordering and therefore you don't need
even leader yeah so this is a bit older
I guess I don't know if you have ever
compared to it
we haven't compared to it I think even
with a pre ordering based on that we're
clocks you still have to do some amount
of coordination to make sure that we
reason which requests they have not just
the order so you're not able to get to a
similar in the sense that you so you get
this proposed messages or mmm-hmm with a
feedstock timestamp and also with a
sequence and as soon your portable you
can know which which message you have
lost and which ones to request again I
think it's real similar better yeah
maybe go calculate hours on a cell line
of sequence so just to summarize this
was a new approach to state machine
replication that Co designing
distributed systems and the data center
network we in the in the common case or
speculative Paxos and with a guarantee
and no Paxos and these are able to give
us nice improvements in replication
performance without having to trade-off
consistency for for it
i want to briefly mention since i know
i'm running out of time some of our
current work more to talk about what the
problem is then the actual solution but
we've seen that this co design approach
can make fault tolerance fast we're also
using this to tackle the harder problem
of making distributed transactions fast
so we were talking before about making
copies of the data on a single server
but we know that applications have way
too much data to actually fit on one
server so we have to partition it into
multiple shards each of which gets
assigned to a server and actually we
want each charge be replicated across
multiple
servers so that means we've got multiple
requests coming in from different users
each of which that wants wants to modify
data on different shards at the same
time we've got a complicated
coordination problem to deal with here
of making sure that applicate app
operations can apply it in the same
order across different shards and on the
replicas within a shard
so distributed transactions are a great
abstraction for doing this we get to
group a bunch of operations together
even when they touch multiple shards and
then the transaction protocol is going
to be responsible for applying them
atomically to all the shards and the
goal here is to provide a strict serial
order of all transactions making it
appear as though they were executing one
at a time on a single machine so users
don't have to worry about a lot of
concurrency issues that come up and
there's a lot of demand for this kind of
functionality like google migrating all
of their advertising data towards
spanner a transactional storage system
specifically so that developers wouldn't
have to deal with data consistency
problems so the reason why distributed
transactions which are a great and old
abstraction are always used is that they
can be really expensive so the normal
approach that's used in systems like
spanner is to use a two-phase commit
protocol to make sure that transactions
execute atomically on all the shards
they affect and this looks kind of like
the coordination we are trying to avoid
in paxos but the situation is actually a
lot worse because each shard is itself
replicated which means we need to run
Paxos at various times through this
two-phase commit protocol to make the
log records persistent and that's not
even all of it because for most of this
time we're going to have to hold a lock
and prevent concurrent transactions from
executing and that's going to keep the
system throughput low in addition to all
the latency we incur from this
coordination so what we're trying to get
to in the system called eros is
something like nope axis did for
replication where we just have a client
send a transaction to all the replicas
in all the shards it affects and have
that transaction arrived in order
and then all the replicas will have to
do is execute that transaction and
respond to the client without even
communicating with each other so this is
an ambitious goal but it's we're able to
achieve it for a certain class of
transactions in a new system we've
developed called eros it's a transaction
coordination framework for distributed
databases that provide strict serialize
ability eros gets named after the Greek
goddess of discord or lack of
coordination and it's optimized for this
class of transactions that we'll talk
about in a minute called independent
transactions and it can execute them
without having to do any coordination at
all which gives us no overhead from
either two-phase commit or replication
so the approach we're taking I'll just
describe at a pretty high level is to
use some transaction techniques to
reduce transaction execution to an
ordering problem and then use a more
advanced version of the network ordering
mechanism we used in no paxos to
efficiently order those transactions so
we've got three insights that are making
this possible the first one is that
we're dealing with two different
coordination problems here insuring with
different Shara's execute transactions
in a consistent order and ensuring that
the replica is within a shard are
executing transactions in the same order
and traditionally these get handled by
completely separate protocols we use
two-phase commit for one of them and
taxes for the other one there's an
opportunity to avoid wasted work by
using a unified protocol to do both
coordination at the post pieces of
coordination at the same time this
introduces additional complexity but
avoid some redundancy and this insight
actually came from our an earlier
project out of our group called paper
that was doing this in the context of
white area transactions the second trick
we're using is to focus on a particular
class of transactions which we call
independent transactions which are
stored procedures that get applied
atomically but don't have data dependent
reads so you can't read a value on one
shard and then you write that value into
a variable on another shard
but you can read or change values on
different shards at the same time now
this is a restrictive model it doesn't
cover everything but it is in fact
useful for building of existing
transactional workloads we know this
because we weren't the ones who came up
with this it actually came out of the H
store work at MIT although they were
never able to actually come up with an
efficient protocol it took advantage of
it later the granola project at MIT did
some work using this model as well the
other thing about these transactions is
that we've shown them this would thrown
in the Aris work that you can actually
use these as a building block to build
up fully general transactions so that
you can start with the independent
transaction model when you have that for
your workload but provide support for
other applications I'll be added some
additional cost and finally we need a
new network ordering mechanism kind of
like no taxes but a little more
complicated the challenge here is that
transactions are a little more
complicated than replication which is
because in the replication world each of
the replicas was receiving messages with
was receiving all the messages in the
system that which means that if it ever
got messages 1 2 & 4 it knew it missed
message 3 and could figure out what it
was supposed to do as a result in a
transaction processing system we don't
have that benefit because that we might
ask you know did we not get message 3
because it was a packet containing a
transaction we were supposed to execute
that just got lost or was it a
transaction that didn't affect this
shard so that makes it a lot harder to
achieve this drop protection property
that was so important in no paxos so
we've actually built a new version of
network sequencing called multi
sequencing that extends oh um - this
multi shard model where the clients
submit messages to a list of
participating shards and the sequencers
maintains a counter for each shard and
stamps it with all the appropriate
counter values so that all the shards
can detect lost packets
and you know the really high-level
summary is that this lets you do this
protocol for eros just like we did with
no paxos where clients and the
transactions using multi sequencing and
the participating replicas just verify
that it's the next transaction in
sequence that they're supposed to
execute and execute it and respond to
the client there's a lot more complexity
in how do you deal with packets that are
lost in out of order and I'm not even
going to talk about that at all other
than to note that this all happens
correctly and off the critical path at
the end of the day we're able to give
you better performance by avoiding this
coordination so a traditional approach
would use a combination of two-phase
commit and Paxos along with locking
that's represented by this spanner dot
here which is our version of the
standard protocol eros is able to give
you a substantial improvement on
workloads likewise ESP with transactions
that because it's avoiding all this
coordination we're able to get a 17 X
improvement in throughput close to a 90%
reduction in latency we also improve on
existing protocols like granola which
provided the same transaction while what
we do and taper which is one of our
earlier pieces of work the other cool
thing about this is that we've also
compared to a non transactional
unreplicated system that's giving you
none of these consistency guarantees and
the performance is within a couple of
percent of what we're able to get out of
Eros so that was a really quick summary
of Eros I don't expect you to have any
understanding of how the protocol
actually works but the point is that
we're able to use the same kind of
technique that we used in no Paxos to
give us coordination free execution for
more complicated applications like
transactional transaction processing as
well
so I want to quickly wrap up by saying a
couple of words about the future of the
data center
I started out by mentioning that you
know our applications today are being
deployed in data centers and the key
word in data center design is commodity
that these are existing served
off-the-shelf servers connected by a
standard Ethernet network so what is the
future data center going to look like
this isn't actually my vision of the
future data center this is actually
Chanel's
data center themed collection from the
last Paris Fashion Week in case anyone
was wondering if the data center was in
it has a broad appeal we're already
starting to see in our data center that
there's a lot more customized Hardware I
talk to programmable switches you know
of course about FPGAs in the context of
catapult and things like that along with
other CRO processors and we're
increasingly seeing disaggregated
resources where we just have a pool of
CPU and memory rather than discrete
servers we've also got a lot more
challenges in the data center we always
have more data but now we're also asking
to do more complicated computation on it
query processing machine learning not
just looking up simple results and we
have less time to do it because we're
deploying this in interactive
applications where we've got a fixed
latency budget and that budget is only
applications are already starting to
strain against that and increasingly
we're moving towards new classes of
applications like a virtual reality
where that latency budget only Falls
even lower but the really nice thing
about the data center environment is
that there's the chance to look at all
the different components of the stack
and see how they'll work together so in
addition to distributed systems and
networks which we already saw you know
there's going to be the need for
operating system support for low latency
and safe sharing of resources we need to
figure out how to manage resources and
schedule
things in order to take advantage of
these new types of customizable hardware
and we're likely going to need
application specific insights and
programming language techniques that
help us get those insights from the
application developers to the underlying
systems in order to take advantage of
applications specific optimizations so
my group has been doing a lot of work in
all of these areas independently and at
the intersection of them but it's really
exciting to think about the fact that we
can now start combining these into a
full stack clean slate redesign of
distributed systems for the data center
so just to finally wrap up the data
center is the important computational
platform we have to deal with it comes
with a lot of distributed systems
challenges related to data consistency
but because we're doing this in the
context of the data center there are a
lot of traditional powerful applications
that are abstractions that are usually
pretty expensive that we can implement
with a low performance cost and what's
making that possible is this new
approach of CO designing distributed
systems and data center networks we've
seen a couple applications but there are
many more I believe so I'd be happy to
take some more questions okay I was like
how when you're sort of Co designing
these things together how is your
approach to developing but especially
testing and debugging changed compared
to traditional so I think how we do
testing and debugging for distributed
systems is a pretty ill-defined area to
begin with there's actually the
potential for this to improve the
maintainability of systems in one sense
because you've got a simpler factoring
it into a simpler primitive that gets
deployed in the network and something
that relies on that in the distributed
system so if you can you know capture
this modularity you know verifying them
independently
is what one way to do that but
definitely we care a lot about this
question and we don't have a great
answer to to this for distributed
systems in general let alone co.design
ones have a very simple I do any using
special to handle conquer overflows or
you see them as fail oh so you have all
these sequencers why I was when that
people's overflow essentially we we use
it essentially the same technique we
would use when we replace a failed
sequencer yeah and you could probably
optimize it a little bit knowing that
it's not an actual failure but that
happens sufficiently infrequently that
there's not much to gain from that
regardless so a lot of the work that you
presented here essentially leverages
switch technologies are coming up right
to improve this routing systems right
yes if you have a say on what the switch
designers should build what would you
suggest what would be the ideal scenario
so we would love to have more
general-purpose programmability in these
switches I think the way I would
describe the current state of the
marketplace is that there's a lot of
pressure on switch vendors to provide
this kind of program ability just
because there's a small number of actual
silicon vendors and a larger number of
resellers who make actual Hardware
actual switch hardware and at the same
time nobody actually knows what this
programmability is going to be used for
we're still collectively trying to
figure that out and to the most people
are thinking about this primarily in the
context of traditional networking
problems but there is less of an
understanding of what you can do where
what the right use cases are at the
application level so
there this is definitely the important
question that we're asking and I think
we don't have enough experience with the
use cases yet to give a really informed
answer I think from you know my
perspective the big question is how much
computation are you able to do within
the context of processing one packet and
how much state are you available to
maintain it seem likely that the amount
of state you're able to maintain is
going to be limited by hardware
constraints because that has to be in
very fast on chip registers or SRAM but
the amount of computation is less it's
less clear whether there's a fundamental
bottleneck there or just no use case for
it yet and presumably what the network
to be as flat as possible to rathe right
speculative axles otherwise you're going
to impose a pretty heavy penalty to go
up all the way to the river loop right
yeah I mean so one of the things that's
making this possible is the fact that we
have these new flat topologies for data
center designs any other questions thank
you all for coming
[Applause]